i had the honor of reading matias
desmet's book
the origins of totalitarianism in its
english translation published by chelsea
green publishing
and
this week
and it's going to be out
again maybe june first i'm not sure like
spanish the spanish edition of our book
and and the english edition of
desmond's book or both out in june june
comes at you past june
probably will be coming out as fast yes
um excuse me and uh in advance of that
you brett are going to do a podcast with
him and um i expect that's going to be a
terrific conversation and i gotta say
this book is just terrific and you know
it pushed me and there's some stuff in
here that i don't agree with um but i'm
i'm trying to frame it you know he's a
i think he's a background in psychology
but he does history um and history of
science and science and he just does a
lot of really terrific things so i want
to read a few excerpts but something you
just said now probably 10 minutes ago
prompted me to want to read this excerpt
first this is um
i don't remember what chapter it's from
the use of numbers in this crisis so
here he's talking about coven okay
pandemic the last two years
the use of numbers in this crisis makes
us barely realize that what we do
respond to are not so much the facts but
the stories constructed around facts
those stories are spun by healthcare
workers who genuinely do their best to
help
by people who don't want to see their
families suffer by politicians who want
to make the right decisions by academics
who want to provide information as
objectively as possible
however they are also constructed by
politicians who are under the pressure
of public opinion and feel compelled to
act decisively by leaders who have lost
control into their opportunity to take
back the reins by experts who have to
hide their ignorance by academics who
see a chance to assert themselves by
man's inherent propensity for hysteria
and drama by pharmaceutical companies
that smell dollar bills by media that
thrive on sensational stories by
ideologies that see in a technocratic
totalitarian system the only solution to
the seemingly insoluble problems of our
time
so this is
this is this is this is brilliant and
there's so much in his book in which
he's basically
railing and that sounds like he's
unhinged which he really really is not
again this is desmet in his book the
origins of totalitarianism which is
going to be published in english in a
couple of months by chelsea green
um in which he takes on
uh the reductionist strictly materialist
in his framing and this is where i kind
of i glitch a little bit
but the very reductionist
view of science that then gets handed
down to people as if all they have to do
is trust the people who say they're
doing the science and then they too are
living in a science state of of mind and
uh they too can hope for sort of a
utopian infinite life future in which
there are no problems right
and
you know what what he reveals here in
part is
not just are the numbers not our saviors
but
we're not even actually responding to
the numbers the numbers on their own
don't don't usually compel people they
compel some of us right the numbers
numbers and
well but not manipulative manipulatively
created graphs and tables will actually
compel those of us who are who are
driven to find meaning in numbers but
that's not most people and even those of
us
uh for whom that is true the vast
majority of us still find meaning in
story
easier and it's easier to remember in an
emotional level at a visceral level and
so what has happened to
us to all of us regardless of where we
fall in terms of what we believe and
what we don't believe what we think is
going on these last two years
is we have we have been handed a series
of stories and very often we don't even
know that because we think we're saying
oh but you know newest studies says
ivermectin doesn't work so it doesn't
work
what are you a horse
yeah that right um
yeah i i wonder sometimes if people
don't need to spend a little bit of time
just
you can tell a lot about the story
you're being handed by figuring out what
the alternatives that could fit in the
same moment in history would be right
like
what what do people think
would have happened if
pharma had discovered
that there was a vast new market for
novel patentable profitable products
and it was unnecessary because a drug
that had gone out of patent was too
effective
what do they think pharma would have
said and done do they think pharma would
have said we are so lucky that one of
our past successes that can now be
produced by anybody because it's out of
patent
uh is capable of controlling this
pandemic
and um you know it would have been nice
from our perspective if this had been a
business win
but um
but it turns out though humanity is
luckier than that and we are
we are grateful
does anybody think anyone in business
ever sounds like that right
right um that said
i think this is a good moment to
actually to read another so wait i want
to take back one thing i said i think a
few people in business do sound like
that but the idea that's that an entire
industry would have reacted that way i
think is preposterous anyway go ahead um
so let me actually just uh kind of
introduce the book so matthias desmet as
many people listening uh will know will
recognize his name uh is
has publicized the idea of mass
formation also known as mass formation
psychosis uh the english you can show my
uh my screen here zach for a minute the
english version of his book the english
translation translation of his book is
being published by chelsea green
uh which is just an extraordinary
publishing company it's one that i had
already been familiar with but you go
through and you find um you know books
um about orchards and farming and covet
19 and pipelines and um you know cobb
houses and all sorts of things it's just
it's just um so lovely and i'm not gonna
do that now thanks chelsea green um but
okay i can i can take my screen back
here um oh and i mean i actually first
came to be i think fully aware of
chelsea green at the point that we were
reading uh derek jensen's books back uh
boy middle mid-aughts probably uh before
we knew him as we are as we are lucky to
to know him now
uh so you know he is a radical
environmentalist and extraordinary
educator as well so this book
um
in this book matthias desmond lays out
uh just a remarkable history and i'm not
i i could have written up an entire uh
description of what it is that he's
doing here but i think uh we'll we'll
just do some excerpts here and you'll
have a conversation with him in in
several weeks and then i will encourage
everyone to read the book and i'll put
the link to the pre-order in the show
notes as well
um but he you know he talks about hannah
arendt uh in the 40s i think i've
forgotten now uh talking about of course
the origins of totalitarianism and
talking about mass formation and also a
french philosopher named leben in 1895 i
believe talking about this phenomenon so
this is not this is neither new with
desmet nor new right now nor is you know
robert malone who has helped you know
publicize uh desmond's work responsible
for causing a bunch of people to believe
in something that he just pulled out of
thin air uh you know this this not that
old ideas are inherently good or new
ideas are inherently bad but this is a
concept this idea of mass formation has
been uh banded about by very smart
people who have seen a lot of truth that
other people have not seen for well over
100 years at this point
yeah i would just say people should
check out um
chris martinson's chat with him they
have a they have a podcast it does
matter yes oh i did not know that that's
uh that's terrific i bet it is
um
okay so
chapter seven the leaders of the masses
um
this is
two pages
the chapter's longer than that the
excerpt i'm going to read is the
beginning of chapter seven which is two
pages
in the previous chapter i described the
again this is from desmet's uh the
origins of totalitarianism
in the previous chapter i described the
phenomenon of mass formation the
psychological basis of totalitarianism
as a form of hypnosis
however there is an important difference
between mass formation and classical
hypnosis in classical hypnosis only the
field of consciousness of the hypnotized
person is narrowed the person who
conveys the hypnotizing story the
hypnotist is awake
in mass formation to the contrary the
person who conveys the story is usually
in the grip of the story as well
in fact this person's field of attention
is usually even more narrow than that of
the masses the reason is clear
the leader usually fanatically believes
in the ideological basis of the
narrative not in the narrative itself
that controls the masses so this is i'm
just stepping aside from the quote for a
moment this is a really critical
distinction he's not saying that the
leader who is effectively uh hypnotizing
masses in mass formation believes the
narrative but he believes that the
reason he's doing it is so honorable
because he believes in an ideology that
it's for their it's it's for everyone's
good it's for the best it's what needs
to happen in order to attain the goal uh
that he or she fervently believes it's a
noble psyop
it is a noble psyop
back to back to desmond's words with
respect to the leaders with respect to
the leaders mass formation gives rise to
two opposing attitudes either one trusts
the leaders blindly and disappears into
the mass or one completely disrupts them
distrusts them and sees them as people
who knowingly carry out an evil plan i.e
conspirators in a certain sense both
extreme perspectives are based on a
similar misunderstanding they
fallaciously endow the leaders with a
virtually absolute knowledge and power
the first group does so in a positive
sense the second group in a negative
sense
other misconceptions are that the
leaders are primarily driven by money
you follow the money and cui bono or
sadistic pleasure i either have a
psychopathic or perverted personality
such statements are not really confirmed
by historical research either to give
one example the head of the nazi party
had a reluctant attitude toward illicit
profits and personalities with
tendencies towards perversion and
psychopathy were system systematically
excluded from recruitment
as opposed to the classical criminal who
finds an intrinsic pleasure in violating
social rules in this case totalitarian
criminality lies more in the uncritical
and mindless adherence to a system of
totalitarian social rules even when the
system becomes radically inhumane and
transcends each and every ethical
boundary
hence hannah arent's famous expression
that totalitarianism was a true
demonstration of the banality of evil
totalitarianism is not about monstrous
people it is about normal people who
stick to a morbid dehumanizing way of
thinking or logic
in the initial phase of the
totalization project process such a
logic first takes hold of the population
the masses or at least a large part of
the population become imbued with
certain ideological convictions that to
them are no longer distinguishable from
reality
the emerging mass movements of
pan-slavism and pan-germanism in russia
and germany in the early 20th century
are good examples
germans typically became convinced that
as a race they were superior to others
and that stigmatization and oppression
of amongst others poles and jews could
be justified by quote the facts
we see something similar happening
during the coronavirus crisis where a
certain segment of the population is
becoming convinced that the facts
justify the social discrimination of
people who refuse to be vaccinated the
numbers show that they are spreading the
virus don't they
these dynamics slowly give rise to the
emergence of totalitarian parties and
totalitarian leaders who gradually
institutionalize this logic and impose
it on society and this typically happens
in a fanatical blind and merciless way
hitler believed that his strength came
from his ability for quote ice-cold
reasoning and stalin believes that the
secret of a success lay in his quote
merciless dialectics
races that were unfit for life and dying
classes were under the justification of
this logic expelled from society with
surgical precision
for this reason what characterizes the
leaders of the masses is not greed or
sadism but their morbid ideological
drive
reality must and will be adjusted to the
ideological fiction
this is
critical i think in part because one of
the questions we often get asked
is does this require conspiracy
does what we are seeing around us
require conspiracy and one of the things
that we get accused of of course is
being conspiracy theorists and of course
that word is just weaponized and that
phrase is just weaponized and
meaningless at this point
and from its origin from
what from its origin what does that mean
um
the phrase conspiracy theory uh emerges
and this is debated by various people
but it emerges in a document in which i
believe it is the cia argues
in favor of using this to effectively
stigmatize people who were not satisfied
with the war and commission's
explanation of what happened to john f
kennedy
and so the idea that this was a way to
get rid of an entire kind of inquiry
is uh from the outset yeah
but
you know
no one
intelligent
and i don't mean educated i mean
intelligent
of which there is some overlap um
not total in either direction
should imagine that conspiracies don't
exist in the world they certainly do if
your bias is to see conspiracy
everywhere every time anything happens
you are no doubt seeing it too many
places and if your bias is to say that
it never happens anywhere then your
biases is in the opposite direction and
is also an error
but what desmet lays out here following
again from a rant and this philosopher
lebon with whom i was not previously um
familiar
is that
it's
in order for the leaders of something
that becomes mass formation to take
place what you need is ideological
certainty
and a belief that they are doing the
right thing they do not need to be
greedy they are not to be conspirators
they do not to be sadists they do not
you know they they actually don't need
to be driven by any of the other things
many of which presumably many of them
are also driven by
but it's not necessary
so um
there's obviously a lot that
one could extrapolate
from here too and one thing that
uh i think is important is the way in
which something that was suffused
through all of the functional apparatus
of western civilization everything
from uh you know from the democratic
party to
the major newspapers
um
to the regulatory apparatus to twitter
right
they're all suffused with something in
advance of the totalitarian impulse
right and so uh
i and others have talked about william
benny describing the turnkey
totalitarian state
the idea that totalitarianism is built
around you but it's not turned on at
first and so it's it's a very much more
frightening thing because you don't see
it it doesn't look like totalitarianism
until somebody flicks the switch on it
um but there's a way in which this
organically happens too right if the
idea is that everybody you know
everybody through all of the control
architecture of western civilization
went through college somewhere right and
as they went through college somewhere
they were fed something that was
very simple
about right and wrong and which side
they were on and who the bad people were
and at the point it was handed to them
it was just sort of an impassing kind of
observation that western civilization is
fundamentally racist for example right
right you can accept that and if
nobody's saying what you're supposed to
do about it then the point is oh well i
guess i believe that and then the point
is at the point they come knocking and
they say well you remember how you
agreed that western civilization was
racist here's what that requires you to
do right your obligation so as to not be
complicit is now x y and z you have to
go after all of the people who don't
agree right for example it's it's a it's
a version of give them an inch they take
a mile once once you've agreed to one of
the premises that um
that
you know may or may not be true
uh if if you can be held to that by your
own moral standards then you can
actually have your morality twisted out
from under you right you have to have
some sort of an active process so that
a you're either the kind of skeptical
person who when they hear western
civilization as racist their question is
what do you mean by that exactly right
right um or you've got to be the kind of
person who when they come knocking and
they say remember how you agreed that
western civilization was racist well now
here's what you're required to do about
it the answer is uh in what way does
this follow and can we go back to your
original assertion because i was always
a bit in doubt about what you meant
do you mean there has been racism
throughout that there have been lots of
barriers placed in people's way i agree
do i agree that that's the fundamental
nature of what western civilization is
about but that's its you know cinquanon
right no i don't agree right and you
know it's very hard to be either one of
those right it's a lot of energy to be
resisting when it seems like nothing's
at stake well um
so i mean i could i could read excerpts
all day and i'll only do a couple of of
more but one of the things i'm reminded
of from what could have been a
three-page excerpt but i but i won't do
it is
you know he says
desmet argues
as
as we have as many others have there's
basically sort of three groups um of of
people and um i mean you've i remember
you describing this before evergreen
blew up in fact four groups okay go for
it so describe describe those groups and
then i'll fit that in this is what i put
on the board two days before uh 50
students i'd never met showed up at my
classroom accusing me of racism uh there
were four groups there were a small
number of people who will
lead who will instigate a witch hunt
there's a large number of people who
will go along with them there's an even
larger group of people who will say
nothing and then there's a tiny group of
people who will stand up and say witches
don't exist and those are your witches
excellent excellent um so
he just hasn't named the leaders as one
of the groups here that's all um
we've identified three groups that form
and mass arises the masters the masses
themselves who truly go along with the
story and are hypnotized he estimates
about 30 percent
a group that is not hypnotized but
chooses to not go against the grain
usually about 40 to 60 percent he
estimates this again desmet and a group
that is not hypnotized and actively
resists the masses ranging from 10 to 30
percent okay that's
us right
probably the the people who are
listening um hopefully there are some in
that middle group i think there's very
few in the first group
who are listening here although i would
hope so he then proceeds and i i won't
read the whole thing here to describe
what it is that if you are in that third
group the group that is not hypnotized
and is actively resisting the mass is
what what you should be doing and why
what the value is in it but the the
key of it the central nugget is
the first and foremost guideline for
members of this third group is that they
should let their voices be heard and in
a sincere away as possible so as not to
let the resonance of the dominant
hypnotic voice become absolute
do it whatever way you can
do it in the grocery store do it on
screens do it with your family you know
just do not
simply be quiet and assume that this
will pass
because that will be how they win
that will be how the dominant hypnotic
mass voice becomes the only voice that
anyone can hear and so then that first
group grows in size and it's pulling
from the second group but the second
group may be growing in size two maybe
pulling even from those who are
currently not hypnotized
um
in his book uh how how extensively does
he go into a connection with renee
gerrard does he i don't think uh at all
it's not there interesting i don't i
it's not i the document i have isn't
searchable so i can't i don't think so
so it seems to me that there's like a
whole little cluster of
uh
people who have studied the same but
apologies i may be misremembering
aspects of the same phenomenon
uh
gerard desmond
orent
um
stanley milgram
ash solomon ash of course yep uh
yeah okay no that's not that's not true
i can search it and gerard isn't in here
not in there ashes interesting um but
anyway it's
the number of places where
you have some
version of
you know the people are hypnotized by
something what is it right is it the
the the lab coat of the experimenter in
stanley milgram's
case that causes people to reflexively
go into a subordinate phase in which
they'll shock somebody to death because
a scientist told them to is it anonymous
peers in the case of ash right is it a
need to
scapegoat in order to find cohesion in
society in gerard's case sorry anonymous
stranger appears yeah anonymous yeah um
anyway all of these things are clearly
explorations of a related set of
phenomena at the very least absolutely
uh how important is it that we figure
this out because we're just going to
keep living it again and again it is so
critical so i am going to
uh read one more short excerpt from
from
desmet and then
two sentences but um
here we go
again all i have is the page number so
remember what chapter this is from
the catalyst for mass formation is a
suggestion in the public sphere
if under the aforementioned
circumstances a suggestive story is
spread through the mass media that
indicates an object of anxiety for
example the aristocracy under stalinism
the jews under nazism the virus and
later the anti-vaxxers during the
coronavirus crisis
at the same time offers a strategy to
deal with that object of anxiety there
is a real chance that all the
free-flowing anxiety will attach itself
to that object and there will be broad
social support for the implementation of
the strategy to control that object of
anxiety
this process yields a psychological gain
firstly the anxiety that previously
roamed through society is a tenebrus
tenebrous fog is now linked to a
specific cause and can mean to be
mentally controlled via the strategy put
forward in the story
secondly through a common struggle with
the enemy the disintegrating society
regains its coherence energy and
rudimentary meaning for this reason the
fight against the object of anxiety then
becomes a mission laden with pathos and
group heroism for example the belgian
government's team of 11 million going to
war against the coronavirus
thirdly in this fight all latent brewing
frustration and aggression is taken out
especially on the group that refuses to
go along with the story and the mass
formation
this brings on enormous release and
satisfaction to the masses which they
will not let go of easily
wow yeah
so much of that is resonant from now a
couple of chapters of our recent life
right it just it's unmistakable right
that
you you're
the experience is certainly one of
facing
a hypnotized group it's like
sleepwalkers and yeah and and
simultaneously
i'm i'm the enemy right what what what
happened and so and many many in our
audience will have experienced this in
at least some ways in these last two
years at this point you know
whether or not
you know wherever they think the virus
came from whatever they think of the
vaccines whatever they think of early
treatment if you're spending any time
listening to us you probably don't
simply accept everything that comes out
of
the cdc's and nih's
mouthpiece's mouths right and so you
probably occasionally say something that
causes people to go what now
and
it's like it's there's a laser focus on
on the person who dissents
on the person who dissents as
uh a place to focus the anxiety like i
now see it i know see that you're the
enemy and now that i have an enemy um i
know what i can do all i have to do is
get rid of the enemy right and it's done
it's amazing how
something has caused
um
the
paradoxical and ironic idea of
scientific consensus sudden scientific
consensus to be the good thing right
gravitating to the sudden consensus puts
you on the side of good and who are the
enemy the enemy are people who are
resisting sudden scientific consensus
and the answer is
sorry scientific consensus is either
over something trivial that's very
easily demonstrated and therefore it
only takes once you know if you drop a
hammer and a feather on the moon they
fall at the same rate right
um
or or some things over in physics space
where it only takes once um like um
einstein's observation of the
gravitational
gravitational lensing uh or you know
even so that's not trivial even the
multi-slit experiment yeah you can see
it in a single instance right right i
agree
with that um but in terms of complex
phenomena right
the thing is the farther you get towards
complexity the more you're dealing with
multiple inputs the more you're dealing
with noise the harder it is to even
describe the pattern in question right
so the idea of sudden consensus around
something like a new virus and what
works to treat it and how it's going to
react to the introduction of that
treatment and all of that this is no
place for it's no place where sudden
consensus is even conceivable
so the idea that those who are the enemy
are those who are resistant to the
sudden consensus it's like well i think
you just
you know painted a target on every
single real scientist
right no and that's um
those who are walking around trying to
experience having a life uh are
presumably not trying to paint target on
every every actual scientist but that is
the effect and so just at the very at
the end of that section that i just read
a couple paragraphs from he writes the
masses believe in the story not because
it's accurate but because it creates a
new social bond
and i think this is a piece that is
often missing from an analysis that
relies entirely on um you know
but why do they believe that like you
know it's not true
and uh especially after two years of the
kinds of
um behavioral modifications and and
experiences that we've all had or rather
failed to have via lockdowns and remote
schooling and zoom meetings and all of
this
the you know the desire for people to
have an actual social bond is even
stronger than it was before which is
hard to imagine because we are above all
social creatures but uh the idea that
the story you know oh i can offer you a
social bond and it happens to come with
a story that uh just don't pay too much
attention to the man behind the curtain
cool i'm not gonna pay too much
attention to the man behind the curtain
because what i really like is now
feeling like the in-group and like we're
on the right path again and i'm moving
towards the future and towards safety
and hey look at all my new friends
and that's just it feels great to people
and that you know that's part of why
they tune in to
you know the mainstream media going
rah-rah look at us aren't we aren't we
all on the right side of history
and
that works as a sales pitch regardless
of whether or not you're actually on the
right side of history
yes the desire to be in that group is so
powerful
that the what what is the group rallying
around is secondary and so lots of
people who you know
feel like
i mean i remember in a prior era right
the
um
the democrats
felt superior
for being the darwinists right they were
never very good at it right but they
were superior in their own minds for
being the ones who had embraced this
very important insight
and it is
as you know you and i both know a
vitally important insight but the point
is most of the people who were feeling
great about being on darwin's team
didn't really understand what the
insight was or why it was so important
they just kind of um
[Music]
had the sense that it was you know that
the enlightened people were ahead in
this regard that darwin's a little hard
to swallow but they were there early
i've actually got so zach just put out
my screen quickly i've got a piece in
huffpo this off post tough po this week
um
no actually it's from march 15th but i
just saw it this week um herschel
walker's skeptical of evolution why are
there still apes think about it
so you know this is a former nfl player
who's now running for senate who doesn't
get evolution and he's a conservative
and so the liberals are really excited
to point out that he doesn't understand
evolution but you read this article and
i'm not going to do it i'm not going to
recommend that you do but i'll post in
the show notes and you see the person
writing the article doesn't get it
either right um you know they they sort
of scored around it but it's clear they
don't really know why
what he said is false they just have
been assured that it's false right and
so you know this this struck me you know
i didn't know you were going to say what
you just said but this struck me exactly
it's like well sure aren't don't we feel
virtuous for understanding this thing
except here too
like i can explain i could explain to
hershel walker or the or the author of
this article why what he said why he is
what his misunderstanding is
and what it actually means that there
are both apes and humans still here
today but neither of the people
and most of the people on both sides of
this argument couldn't do it and so it's
entirely it's back to that newsweek
thing it's like it's about it's about
judgment as opposed to reality and
science right which leads to one of my
least favorite moves in analytical space
right which is when somebody is caught
in that bind right where they know
herschel walker is not
onto something by having discovered that
they still exist right they don't know
what's wrong with what he said and so
the point is oh the last thing i want to
do is say he's wrong and then have
somebody say oh really why so what they
do is they amplify how obvious it is
that he's wrong and how obvious it is
why he's wrong so that they basically
bluff and they say anybody who doesn't
know why that's wrong
is a fool so then the point is if you
ask the question you're
stepping into the role of fool aren't
you so you wouldn't want to do that so
you're not going to ask me the question
are you and it's created in order not to
be asked i mean just as you said like
okay i don't want to have to pronounce
anything here because the fact is i
don't understand this
so i'm going to be really loud and
bombastic about making fun of the people
who think the other thing that's exactly
what we're seeing with regard to the
braz the together trial being published
you know all you know both both
individuals and and mainstream media
pronouncing loudly what a you know what
a fool joe rogan is and you know and we
are and all of this like none of you
actually have
bothered to try to understand the
science right you know they're revealing
how little they know about um how the
thought process even works right what
the underlying philosophy of science
that makes the engine function is right
they don't know and they're revealing it
to us they're not revealing it to other
people who don't know
um
and so anyway it's maddening
um but but nonetheless it is effective i
just realized that i misspoke several
times in the first hour i don't know
yeah i'm not going to tell you how i
know i am um do you want to redo yeah
yeah i want to read you um i kept con i
conflated
the title of hannah rent's book which i
knew i was doing um
but desmond's book is the psychology of
totalitarianism yep not the origins
which i knew that was a rant's book
anyway
oh well
it's done i almost corrected jeff yeah
but then you're like well she just read
it
yeah i didn't know what the title was i
thought maybe it was a
slight play on it i mean it is it just i
got yeah anyway
[Music]
you